hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff we are continuing our 1858
clash between henry edward bird
and paul charles morphy and as you can
see the uh switched colors now bird
finally has the white pieces
and the morphe is now black but like i
said not all of the games from this
encounter were saved uh probably only
only the nicer ones
and this one uh this is uh one of the
most famous games ever
not only one of morphy's most famous
games ever but
one of the most famous games in general
and
if you've picked up uh chess book
featuring some maybe nicer games
from chess history uh chances are this
game has been featured in that book
so uh some of you have seen it but i
imagine most of you haven't uh so uh i i
do hope you
you will enjoy it uh without further ado
bird with the white pieces opens with e4
you might think okay he's henry bird he
might go for the birds opening but no
this is a bit too early for that so here
we have e4
uh morphe replies with e5 we have knight
f3 d6
and now d4 so morphe goes for the
philidor's defense and of course you
uh immediately charging the center with
the d4 and now
f5 uh this is the so-called felder's
counter gambit uh in in the field of
defense
and now knight to c3 bishop to c4
would would be probably played nowadays
as it offers white uh
uh the most advantage but okay in those
days knight to c3
we have f captures an e for knight
captures uh and
now morphy advances his pawns in the
center d5 attacks the knight here
knight goes back to g3 also uh night
night here would be possible even
capturing an e5 would be possible as it
offers white to very very interesting
play for example characters captures and
uh queen to h5 check uh poses a lot of
problems for black if g6 then you can
capture here and so on so morphe is
really
uh testing out uh uh henry's ability to
you know calculate stuff but he retreats
with knight to g3
and now uh we have e4 so morphe really
got some counterplay and his gambit paid
off
with knight to e5 and now knight to f6
morphe continues development with bishop
to g5 that's not a g5 bishop to g5
pinning the knight and now bishop to d6
not going bishop to e7
morphy says there is no uh no reason to
play defensively we can just advance it
all the way
and now knight to h5 bird doesn't waste
any time and he immediately wants to
pile up on this knight here
so castles morphy defends it once again
and now
uh well you could capture here for
example knight captures
uh black is very happy just captures and
now both of your pieces are under attack
so
not really gaining all that much even
though you must open the king's defenses
so queen to d2 first and now queen to e8
putting pressure on the knight as the
queen just left the d1 square so no
longer defending the knight on a
on h5 and here uh we have g4
just defending that knight however this
allows the morphe to
to will really uh get a lot from the
position he starts with
knight captures on g4 so he removes one
of the defenders
not one of the only defender of the h5
knight
we have knight captures and g4 and now
queen captures on h5 attacking the
knight on g4
so knight back to e5 and now knights the
c6 and here
bishop to e2 attacking morphy's queen uh
and when the queen moves uh well
bird is most likely to castle queen side
with queen to h3
and now uh first uh a capture on c6 we
have knight captures on c6 uh if you
castle right away
uh then you run into some well some
unpleasant ideas as the f2 pawn is
undefended you can go rook captures uh
on f2 so instead uh first knight
characters on c6 was played b captures
and now
bishop back to e3 just defending that
[Music]
uh f2 pawn so rook the b8 by morphy now
attacking the b2 pawn and practically
inviting white to castle
and this is exactly what bird does he
castles queen side the defends the b2
pawn with his king
and now comes one of the most beautiful
moves and
one of the more uh well one of the most
beautiful
ideas uh uh you know ever ever played
over the chess board here morphy strikes
with rook captures on f2 there are many
other moves here
you could just continue the game
normally you have very nice play you
have an open
b file to use for your attack you can
simply develop
then double up rooks on the b file so
there are many options here however
morphe goes for the immediate
rook captures on f2 and it's a really
weird move
uh because you're giving up the whole
rook and there doesn't seem to be any
immediate compensation for that rook
or or compensation in general ah so
not not uh accepting this rook sacrifice
uh doesn't really work for uh for white
if you try something like rook to g1
to put some pressure maybe here doesn't
really work uh because you can just play
rook captures characters
captures and now there's no way to put
any pressure if
if bishop to h6 trying to put pressure
on g7 then the bishop no longer guards
the rook so you can capture it so there
there's nothing here for white
so after this rook captures on f2 bird
had to capture the rook so
bishop captures an f2 but now comes
morphy's idea
and yes we have reached the position
from the thumbnail uh morphe plays
queen to a3 and this is incredible first
a rook sacrifice then
a queen sacrifice as the title suggests
and uh there's uh well
there are options here for white but one
of them is definitely not
accepting the queen because that's just
mate in one bishop captures on a3
delivers checkmate as the rook controls
the entire b
file and the king is in check so what
can you do here
well c3 was played trying to make at
least some room defending the b2 pawn
with the queen
and now comes queen captures on a2 so
once again
how do you defend this position it's not
an easy position to defend
and there is only one good move for
white here for example just to give you
an idea
uh if you try something like queen to c2
to maybe
go for a nice king while get your king
to safety it doesn't work because just
bishop to f4
check and now whatever you do just loses
terribly the king has nowhere to go
you'd have to block with the rook but
now just captures
and it doesn't matter if the queen or
king captures because if you capture
with the king then just rook captures on
b2
uh wins the queen and if you capture
with the queen it's not much better uh
because just
queen a1 check king to c2 and now rook
captures on b two delivers checkmate as
the pawn here now covers the d3 square
so not possible the only move that is
possible in this position is the move
bird played and that is b4
so uh wha what can you do here uh well
morphe continues
by checking the white king with queen to
a1 with
check king to c2 and now queen to a for
with
check and now here we have a a very
interesting position where you can
just repeat moves you can go king to c1
and then morphe will have the option of
either
repeating with queen a3 checking c2 and
then queen back or he will have to try
something
uh either bishop to f5 trying to get
some uh
some counterplay here but it would be
the best idea for white
however uh bird is up a whole rook and
he definitely doesn't want to draw this
game he wants to
to win it after all he's down uh by a
lot in the match
so here after queen to a for check he
tried king to b2
and yes this stops uh all in the any
checks with the queen however there is
one move that morphe has here and that
move unfortunately for
uh henry bird wins the game for black so
feel free to pause the video
and win the game for morphe uh while i
give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on finding the
only winning idea for black
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's bishop captures on
b4
and now you can see that this opens up
the b file for the black rook and there
is nothing the the white king can do
uh for example if you ignore the bishop
and try something like rook to a1 you
want to attack black's queen
it's it's a very quick checkmate to just
bishop to a3 check king a2 and bishop
the c1 now opens up a discovery the rook
controls the entire b
file and white king is in checkmate so
after this bishop captures on b4 uh bert
said all right uh there's
not much to be done here we're gonna
give up the queen so here we have
captures captures with check captures
and now
queen again captures with check so
uh what what can you do here uh again
not much
uh but you do have some counterplay you
still have two rooks and two bishops and
it's very interesting
uh there is another game uh aside from
this one that reached this position if
you've uh
if you've been paying attention you
might have noticed i haven't said uh
it is as of this move that we have a
completely new game
because there is another game from 1998
that reached
this exact same position and it ended in
a draw uh it was
again between arnold leclair and nicolas
turpin
uh and uh well i i think what happened
here was that the two of them
were just you know trying to make a joke
they wanted another game in the database
to reach this position or maybe they
were you know pulling uh
uh you know trying to pull a prank on
someone i don't know uh but it's very
interesting that someone would do this
and then agree to a draw in this
position however morphy's game against
bird of course continued from this
position
and king to c2 was played so it is as of
this move that this position has never
been reached again and we are already at
move 25 so that's uh
you know a bit a bit interesting
uh and now morphe needs a way to
continue as he only has a bishop and the
queen against an army of white's pieces
against
two rooks and two bishops but morphy
easily finds the idea
e3 he just opens up the path towards the
white's king
and it's not going to be easy to stop
this you have to react to this because
your bishop on f2 is under attack
so here bird captures it but now bishop
to f5 check
and with the queen slicing all the way
here uh you don't really have
a lot of options here if you go king to
c1 queen to c3 is just
checkmate all of the squares are covered
here the bishop slices through here
so after bishop to f5 you could block
with the bishop but here morphy just had
a queen to see for
check in mind of course the queen cannot
capture it because the queen
king would be in check you'd have to
move it and then just bishop captures
and now it's actually black who is up
material
so uh bert tried one last uh idea
rook to d3 at least he will be able to
guard
the rook with his king after queen to c
for chuck but it doesn't help
all that much morphe continue with queen
to c for chuck
king to d2 and now comes queen to a2
with check the king has to move king to
d1 was played and now comes queen to b1
check with a double attack on the rook
here and also if the king moves the rook
on h1 falls
so it was in this position on move 29
that henry edward bird resigned the game
and this wonderful wonderful game was
created
that uh with perfect play bird could
have drawn but
he's already down so much in the match
and he wanted to try and win this game i
imagine
because you don't miss uh okay first i'm
going to show you what happens here
because well there's nothing you can do
if you just capture it
or move the king for example bishop to
c1 you can just capture on d3 and after
characters captures with check of course
the queen
will be able to overcome the the bishop
and rook especially with so many pawns
here
and if you do something else like move
the king uh just queen captures on h1
is sufficient for black to again uh
win the game easily uh so yeah after
this uh
queen to b1 checked the game ended and
this beautiful beautiful masterpiece was
created but this
shock this incredible idea that
happened way way before adam bird ever
decided to try and pull off this win uh
happened
very very early on in the game uh when
morphe uh
after this uh well uh
castles uh played rook captures on f2
this is this is just incredible because
berth thought
okay i know my bishop protects
everything this protected this protected
there's nothing black can do
but morphy just said first i'm going to
sacrifice the rook
and then i'm going to sacrifice my queen
or you know just offer a queen sacrifice
and this is just
this is pure art and this is uh well
this is uh
amongst other things one of the reasons
why i started
really enjoying chess because i had some
really old chess books from my
grandfather and
you know it featured games like this and
i was like wow
uh so yeah unfortunately for us this is
the last game
we'll be showing uh from the match henry
bird versus paul morphy
because only four games were recorded
from this match
even though the final score of the match
was uh well out of the 12 games they
played
uh morphy won 10 games drew one and only
lost one to henry bird
i wish we had the one that bird want to
show that one as well but we don't we
only have these four
and unless they somehow somewhere
resurface one day uh we are stuck with
with uh these four now uh
it's uh hard to say where we are uh
continuing with uh the morphe saga but
uh first i just wanna read you a very
very short letter
so this is it for the game so those of
you who just came for the game that's it
but now i have one letter i want to read
for you
it's a letter from paul morphy uh to
howard staunton about the match
and uh you know why why is it taking so
long and when the match might happen
so again it's from lawson's book if you
if you have a chance uh
try and get it it's uh you know the
biggest ever collection of anything we
know
uh on paul morphy so the book is just
basically a bible on morphe
so here it says uh morphe uh uh
addressing staunton
dear sir i first uh i must first
apologize for not replying to your
previous communication
as you observe my numerous contests uh
must be the excuse for my
remissness uh it is certainly a high
compliment to so young a player as
myself that you whose reputation in the
chess arena has been
unapproached during so many long years
should require
any preparation for our match uh
immediately on my arrival in england
some two months since i spoke to you in
reference to our contest and in
accepting the challenge
you stated that you should require some
time to prepare and you proposed a
period for commencing which i accepted
i am well aware that you that your many
engagements in the literary world must
put you to some
inconvenience in meeting me and i am
therefore desirous to consult your
wishes in every respect uh would you
please state the earliest opportunity
when those engagements will permit
the match coming off such time being
consistent with your previous
preparation
the few weeks referred to in your favor
seem to be rather vague and i shall feel
highly gratified by your
fixing a definite period for the contest
i'll leave the terms entirely to
yourself i remain dear sir
yours very respectfully uh paul morphy
so this is what uh morphy sent to uh to
howard stanton however staunton uh did
not reply to the letter and he
uh left uh he left uh
he left london uh leaving morphy without
a reply
and uh well he did mention that uh
that morphy should not uh join the the
great
tournament that will take place in
birmingham and
that he also will not attend this
tournament but morphy said that even if
uh even if staunton were to play in the
uh birmingham uh tournament that uh
meeting him in a tournament would not be
as concise as meeting him uh uh in a
match over a game let's say over
12 games or you know because i mean uh
meeting staunton is why morphy came to
england in
in the in the first place of course he
wanted to play other masters as well
but he wanted to play the absolute best
and howard staunton was that
so uh the problem is uh after you know
some time
and before the birmingham tournament uh
commenced staunton actually applied to
play in the tournament
uh however he said that morphe shouldn't
apply and that he should just wait uh
for uh for stanton to accept his
challenge and morphy said
that uh he he doesn't really want to
apply for the tournament and he said
that he's gonna
only arrive in birmingham after the
tournament actually starts
because he uh he feels that he will not
be able to
control himself if if he has the
opportunity to enter the tournament he's
going to enter the tournament
so what happens in birmingham and uh
what
uh well what happens next in our saga
will be addressed in the next video
the next video will uh you know uh
we're gonna talk about the events that
took place uh at the birmingham
tournament uh
probably i don't know if we'll be
showing any games but we might
but mostly to discuss what happens and
then we're gonna see where we are
heading with the morphe saga will the
match against danton take place or
maybe maybe you know maybe it won't uh
but yeah
uh that's it for this video uh you know
i i really
hope you guys enjoyed it as this is one
really really famous game
uh you know do show it to everyone uh i
would like to thank
boris saradenshak uh mustafa hussein a
mystery person john earhart and
william will for contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
uh continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and
whatever else happens in the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day